las vegas is the fight capital of the
world and tomorrow night the ladies will
be taking center stage at the sahara
hotel with a debut of the ultimate women
of wrestling here to tell us more is the
league's general manager welcome jenny
santana it's great to see you hey it's
great to see you too it's nice to
finally meet you too i'm a fan i know
it's yes it's finally nice to meet you
so thank you for having me and uww a
little bit about us we are an
all-women's wrestling promotion
so as you said we're in the fight
capital of the world it is going to be
women celebrating women women learning
from women this empowering organization
we are featuring women of all races
ethnicities sizes ages
there are women who have wrestled
most of the roster has wrestled across
the united states but many have wrestled
you know throughout the entire world and
so our roster is so unique we have seven
different languages represented by the
girls on our roster yes tomorrow night
the sahara hotel what an iconic hotel to
be wrestling into nothing but ladies in
the rain taking center stage tomorrow
night your role is general manager are
you going to be in charge of the chaos
what is your role there tomorrow night
yeah so i'm going to be in charge of the
chaos we're going to
um the driving force behind uww is just
top uh caliber athleticism and passion
in the ring so definitely it's gonna be
a task too these ladies are all hungry
and they're going after what they want
and so yeah someone has to be uh
overseeing all of that so that's a big a
big task but i think i'm up for it and i
love you you're you're a las vegas girls
funny we're talking before the interview
we've seen each other at lvac we work
out at the same gym and there's another
wrestler tomorrow is it maserati she's a
vegas girl wrestling tomorrow night
maserati is a vegas girl and she's doing
great things so i mean her opponent they
are the main event on the card ivelisse
is her opponent and she is an 18-year
veteran
but so she has whole world she has many
world titles but maserati you know she's
got the hometown crowd behind herself i
mean at vegas is nothing to you know
vegas crowds uh they're rooting for
maserati tomorrow yeah i think they
might be we we'll see i believe has a
ton of fans too so and a lot of people
are making the trip because sahara is
packed you know it's a great hotel
iconic now jenny santana you are the
daughter of wwe hall of famer tito
santana yes i am yeah i just found out
that he was my biological father a few
years ago but i was able to uh see him i
think it was like last week or two weeks
ago he was at a convention signing and
you know we talked about me using the
name he was all for it so and just you
know wishes me success in the the career
that he's uh been so successful yeah
it's interesting too his his life path
was wrestling hall of famer then your
life path also brought you into the
world of fighting and pro wrestling you
got both following the same life path
yeah it was so similar and you know
when i found out i looked at his his
life you know and he's an athlete i'm an
athlete he had the football career
before wrestling i am doing jiu jitsu
i'm still training and competing but
then he works at a high school as a
spanish teacher and i also am in
education employed by ccsd and so like
very many similarities even though yeah
we weren't kind of we were i wasn't
raised with him so i love it jenny
santana thank you so much tomorrow night
is the big event at the sahara hotel and
they can also watch it on pay-per-view
as well yeah so please if you're
anywhere near las vegas come down to
sahara check it out and then if you are
not please we are doing a pay-per-view
on title match network it's 9.95 so
follow us on instagram uwbfat all the
links are there to get the tickets or
the pay-per-view thank you so much jenny
las vegas now we'll be right back